happy weekend today is Saturday I
decided to bring
the girl and the boy to the park
oh and since it's springtime they turn
on all the little splash pads and I'll
show you real quick
taika has the craziest Bed Head Tykes
come here
turn around
look at that you got Bed Head dude
let me know everybody knows nobody knows
look they have the splash pad
you can get wet over there oh you gonna
do it
okay hold my beer
oh okay
this guy's a Maniac Run tiger run in It
Go
let me see
go Tykes
[Music]
it's like a turned on the splash pad
will he get in oh nice
why does this always get
the craziest ideas stop it
[Music]
oh man I can't wait for that to get in
him
[Music]
all right
is it cold
sorry Mia keeps pulling the leash
getting me a kid at me I'm kidding me I
get it
get the water
[Music]
get it
are you proud of yourself Mia
oh yeah are you hey are you proud of
yourself
okay taika
oh my God let me see your shoes
how is the water
is it super fun
would you do it again
[Applause]
you look like you're cold dude
okay let me know when you want to go
home
your bed head is still there you want
everything except for your bed head so
we just got back home it's like it got
really cold after
um jumping around in the Splash Zone I
mean I don't mind because one he's cold
too we also live really really close to
the park so
um I just asked him if he wanted to come
home change yes he said we're here he's
gonna change and then we'll go right
back
um but yeah I had him take off his
clothes
have it in the dryer because they're not
dirty he literally just wore them for
five minutes
um and then with the shoe situation
normally I wouldn't let him get
shoes like that wet
um just because it's a to try like
and you don't want to put them in a
dryer unless you have like a special
drawing what does it set we could put
them in there but it's a hassle and then
the toe part of the shoe never really
gets that dry so then I feel like it
starts growing some sort of mold or
mildew and it's just kind of sticky
so
I um one time was on a few years back
not went to but shopped on Amazon found
the boot dryer
and it's been a lifesaver ever since so
this one in particular is by dry guys
not sponsored it was one of the ones
that had the higher ratings I got it I
haven't tried anything else out so I
don't know if this is good or bad I just
know that it does the job
um essentially it just
um uh emits just warm air and it puts it
inside the shoe but it's not enough warm
air where it's going to ruin the shoe or
you have to have it on for a certain
amount of time or it's gonna like burn
it or whatever it's just enough to dry
the shoe but just but it's not hot
enough to damage it so something like
this where it's like really thick suede
might take about
several hours to dry oh my God this
thing is drenched
um even his hiking boots take about two
days to dry but they are so dry like the
toe part the inside part the toe part is
super duper dry I've used it multiple
times and it's the so that's what
we're doing now Mia's a little bit damp
but she's fine I'll probably just bring
her back it's like it's changing
yeah we're just gonna go right back to
the park oh really
I just let you run for 10 minutes
you're tired
okay
okay new park also close to the house
this one's cool why did you pick this
one
of my favorites is it because of that
thing that high ginormous slide
[Music]
oh okay you still have Bed Head
okay Tech is going to come down this big
ass slide head first ready Tykes
go
are you okay that looks so violent are
you okay
where did you get did you get dizzy
okay get out of there because there
might be someone else coming down
hi everybody
backwards but I always I always go down
um
you're so cute all I said was just tell
them just say that you're coming down
the slide you think you need I could
jump out anybody sure
foreign
okay let me know when you're ready
okay go okay go
how was that
watch this
that was the cutest introduction ever
all I said was okay just say that you're
gonna go down the slide and then I
turned the camera on he goes hey
everybody and then he just did all that
himself I think he just watched this
vlog
he's a pronoun he's better than us
so we're back home want to make sure
tiger gets his nap in especially because
we have company over
um silent Mike is here
so I know they're going to want to grab
lunch because they're out of meet right
now but I know the lunch is right around
the corner tiger usually takes a nap
around two right now it's 12. they
should be here on like one-ish so
um I just want to get his nap in early
to ensure that he has a good quality of
sleep so he's already changed his
pajamas he always has to drink his milk
bushy so I found this bushy
see
here monkey monks he has a little cough
so I have humidifier I have Vicks Vapor
Rub on his chest gave you some cough
medicine sorry
and there's bushy what
okay good night monkey I'll see you in a
bit okay
[Music]
oh thank you okay one second okay I'm
gonna put this little duty to bed
and tell him I kept the obvious
conversations but I would like some Bo
Jackson's and if you must go to your
mama's tummy to make them I think that's
okay
then my mom's gonna die somebody has to
cut her stomach well I think that's an
okay sacrifice for some cool shoes or
maybe I have to go to my mom's son again
yeah
um
[Music]
and we're gonna break our Channel
because I'm still big
wow you don't want him to go in his
mom's China
I don't even want to talk about your
mom's China but I would like some
sneakers I don't know where we got to
taika you jump some hoops to get there
she was not crying but that was the
biggest China I've ever seen
[Laughter]
my sneakers are in China are you is this
a Nike joke I don't really get people
are making them in China this is Gen
Alpha One Alpha One Delta Two I don't
know I don't know where did the feed
come into play because it's he's like
his dad he thinks
you were climbing on some blood vessels
do you remember that you have a good
memory yeah I was cleaning on my little
vessel to get out from my mom's now yeah
her mouth yeah are there shoes up there
or just annoying noises I was just
making it in her stomach and then I was
crying because when I think of your
mom's mouth I just think of all the
annoying noises that come out
what do you hear
I get out and then put it in
and when I was a baby and then they
jumped did you jump so high though
because you had the bojacks from the
China
have you heard of the chicken to China
the Chinese chicken yeah you heard of
that that's pretty good what did you
hear about it what do you know about
that I don't know I
jumped and I put it there on that old
house and then and then I went and then
I went away
and everybody and I was naked why were
you naked with Bo Jackson's on
crazy
crazy so it did not
it's alive all over body
yeah because I look so nasty I don't see
any other stuff on me
see through
because that's saliva Cedar right yeah
in my mom's stomach there's blood
in my mom's blood I could drown
well you made it look look at you now
now you're jumping high enough to go on
the swing set moral of the story
that was a long way to get to jump high
but you did it we gave you all the
context yeah what's moving see that see
that
at some cave beach now and uh Papa's
looking at all the choices I never order
here just because I won there's just way
too many choices too I don't know the
hell I'm ordering and I take care of you
so good you literally have zero stress I
think my battery's running out I always
like I lay out your life so easy it's
just so smooth it's like first class
life where where do we leave where can
you find uh extra paper paper can you
speak see I like you don't even know how
to speak your muscles at literally at
your feet because I've taken care of
yourself
why are you even here I'm here for the
KBB in time
[Music]
do you even know how to parents anymore
do I make your life yeah do you even not
a parent oh my God
what do you think's gonna be in a water
cup
what other kind of Cups you got
it so what were you getting it for
[Applause]
Mike being an absolute dog all he wanted
was just to chew on the bones look at
that they said I don't need the beat
just the passing everything hard and
inedible yeah he's doing it look at that
disgusting
that's good right no it's good yeah
um
Papa got a really good spread and I
didn't show any of it other than this
up like Grill now oh well
is it yummy was this a good call
thank you thank you is it a good call
very good call yummy
all right taika what are you doing
oh my God
[Applause]
so intrusive
what the he out of nowhere she nibbled
on my chin okay sorry what are we doing
some Legos and we already built some
right can you show me the ones you built
already
on
[Applause]
there we put some stickers on
everywhere else okay let's do some let's
do the other one
now we're gonna do book two we just did
book one I'm not sure what book two is
gonna end with oh I think we're gonna do
the spaceship
and then what's this one oh Rocky ship
I'm so sorry oh I don't know I don't
know what book two is okay we'll see
we'll see book two okay this is ready
this is book three okay he's in number
three got it
okay okay
got it
all right all right so taika has put all
the colors together makes it easier
right when you're building Okay now
what's your favorite oh I see one that
thought up yeah there you go what's your
first step that and that okay show me
yep let's see look at this yeah
are you putting it the right way it's
not backwards this is backwards did you
just fart
disgusting is it backwards excuse me I
know now my face is right there I wonder
where you learned that from his dad
let me see nice no one needs ahead wait
I think which one's the front which is
the back oh I think you put them on
backwards
yeah it's backwards this the front pull
them apart come on
I can't okay I'll help you oh he's he's
dead
I just had to destroy our progress back
to zero we miscalculated some of the
buttons and we were short two buttons
and I couldn't figure it out it was
pretty sad yeah so what do we do now put
it away and just kind of take a break
yeah this girl wants to play maybe we
can do tomorrow yeah
laughs
yeah Bob what do you mean she wants to
play fetch look that's how she asks to
play fetch okay
okay so it's 7 30 which makes it about
eight hours since I've put those
drenched shoes to dry on the boot dryer
let's see where we're at I want to see
whereabouts oh Jesus
oh hold on
what a mess I am it's a two-hand
operation okay so I think
as you can see here the color's already
different the whole back side of this
shoe is already dry it's just the toe
part
that is still damp so is the tongue I
want to say we're about
85 percent dry at this point you
remember it was like soaking wet like
you can kind of see the minerals from
the water that dried this is literally
like 40 bucks it's quiet dude am I like
I'm like trying to convince you and I
don't know why I think I'm just so
impressed like I'm like pushing this
product on you for no reason other than
I think it's so cool I'm done but yeah
use my code I'm just kidding
um use my code at checkout no out of my
book because it's not sponsored but dude
save your shoes get the boot dryer
papa is finally back I feel like I never
see you these days
we're finally gonna sleep together I
mean we slept together last night but
you got in at like 2 A.M and then you
left this morning seven yeah seven A.M
busy busy days these days
you look really nice you look really
lean you're getting after it in every
aspect of life
you look great
I'm so exhausted it's almost 11 and I'm
dying right now okay I know thank you so
much
see you tomorrow okay bye